hallo mein name ist luca und ich bin
schon relativ dummen doch es gibt
wirklich noch dümmere menschen als mich
ich war nämlich mal wieder auf der
website gutefrage.net unterwegs wo
irgendwelche leute irgendwelche fragen
stellen können und diese teilweise echt
dumm und auf einige reagieren wir heute
das ist die erste frage soll ich
schlafen gehen oder lieber noch eine
pizza essen ja die wichtigen dinge im
leben ich habe die ganze nacht
durchgemacht und könnte mich jetzt ins
bett legen ich kann aber auch auf
bleiben und pizza essen ich kann mich
nie entscheiden und wenn ich pizza essen
soll
vegetarisch oder salami das ist so
ähnlich schwierige entscheidungen die
leute haben dann beispielsweise so was
geantwortet wie schlafen und dann
vegetarische pizza dann hat man was auf
dass man sich freut wenn man wach wird
oder auch ich würde lieber erst schlafen
danach salami pizza essen
warum
denkt man sich
ja die frage beantwortet
direkt weiter mit der nächsten frage und
zwar meine katze ist hey was kann ich
tun
ja meine
hat morgens wenn sie nach hause kommen
pupillen von denen sich jeder junkie
alle mal eine scheibe abschneiden kann
sie ist komplett durcheinander und liegt
nur herum wenn sie sich einmal bewegt
dann zittert ihr ganzer körper unsere
tierärztin hat schon bestätigt dass
unsere katze hai ist in der natur wächst
anscheinend etwas genannt katzenminze
normalerweise wälzen sich die türen oder
erin um sich zu beruhigen oder so aber
meine katze frisst diese dinger
andauernd die beste antwort auf diese
frage kommt von dem user mehr zeri an
der schreibt nämlich rede offen mit ihr
zeige ihr die folgen ihrer sucht auch
vielleicht ist sie bereit an einem
methadonprogramm teilzunehmen erkundige
dich vorsichtshalber ob deine katze sich
strafbar macht weil sie gegen das
betäubungsmittelgesetz verstößt
vielleicht ist es auch möglich den
tiefer bloßzustellen und damit die
drogen fuhr nach id zu beschränken ist
das fördere die nächste frage ist
einfach so komplett bescheuert aber
irgendwie auch gar nicht mal so dohmen
haben flugzeuge eine hupe ganz im ernst
ich bin ich gespannt worden
jetzt allerdings wirklich immer die
frage ernsthaft beantwortet und zwar
juhu was seid ihr alle bis ich okay hier
eine ernste antwort ja sie haben eine
hupe die dazu dient am boden dem
bodenpersonal verständlich zu machen
dass die cockpit crew von ihnen etwas
haben will also flugzeuge haben
tatsächlich eine hupe mit der sie so
richtig weg gucken können
also ich denke jetzt nicht dass sie im
himmel irgendwie anderen flugzeugen
sagen er geht vecchi kommt ein anderes
flugzeug
das wäre auch eigentlich schon viel zu
spät wenn man die hupe von einem anderen
flugzeug gehören würde wieso passiert
immer genau so viel wie in die zeitung
passt
also
ganz im ernst frage ich mich wirklich
warum sowas nicht entfernt wird oder
rausgenommen wird und wichtigeres wird
weggelassen
danke herr jetzt gar nicht gedacht die
nächste frage wirklich wieder da fragt
man sich ob sie wirklich mit einem
herzen hintergedanken gestellt wurde
kann man wirklich schamhaare rauchen
ein freund von mir meinte dass der scham
heraus und ich frage mich jetzt ob das
wirklich möglich ist
also ja man kann
alles rauchen weil man so ca alles
anzünden kann allerdings warum über das
machen
schaal haare sind auch wenn man sie
nicht raucht schon ekelhaft genug bei
der nächsten frage bin ich ganz ehrlich
da kann ich mir wirklich vorstellen dass
sich da so ein 11 12 jähriger gedacht
hat hey ich frage das mal und zwar mit
welchem auto kriegt man die meisten
frauen ab die beschreibung ist auch
stark ein nachbar hat einen bmw m3 und
hat jedes wochenende mädels am start der
einfach mal ein bmw m3 kaufen und du
hast keine sorgen mehr was frauen angeht
oder man kauft sich einfach den runter
gesetzten christmas with in den
antworten steht halt wieder so was wie
hey ya normale frauen stehen nicht nur
auf geld und autos ja aber wenn du zur
nächsten frage die da bin ich ganz
ehrlich die stellt sich glaube ich fast
jeder junge oder vielleicht auch mädchen
kurz unterdrücken in der schule wo steht
da kann mir keiner von euch sagen dass
er nicht schon mal einen furz
unterdrückt hat in der schule immer wenn
ich in die schule gehe kriege ich
irgendwie die übelsten blähungen da ist
mir peinlich ist im unterricht zu kurzen
unterdrücke ist ja auch komisch erinnern
alles ruhig ist unsere klassenarbeiten
da kommt so ein vom fenster platz
das wäre ein bisschen komisch da durch
kriege ich sehr starke magenschmerzen
dann muss ich immer aufs klo rennen und
kacken zum glück sind die fragen die
anonymen twin unter der furz frage gar
nicht die ganzen antworten anschauen
weil der in europa stehen die hlg zum
arzt blablabla er stattdessen widmen wir
uns den wichtigen dingen leben und
wirklich richtigen problem von richtigen
menschen ist es schädlich jeden tag eine
flasche bockwurst wasser zu trinken
dsl komplett gesund trinken wie gesagt
ja eine bockwurst wasser bin aber der
gesundheitsrisiken nicht bewusst welche
existieren dann bitte ich euch mir sie
aufzuzählen lieber mit bei 98 so heißt
der typ der die frage gestellt hat das
was mir spontan einfällt ist das
bockwurst wasser sehr salzig ist achter
also gut darauf umso mehr leitungswasser
mineralwasser zu trinken damit der
körper nicht austrocknet also die frage
wurde hier ernst beantwortet dann gibt
es allerdings noch den leben sack fed
presse der schreibt sie solltest dich
auch mit bockwurst wasser einreiben
vielleicht findest du ja einen nebenjob
im tierheim und kümmert sich dort um
hunde also genauso hätte ich das
eigentlich auch beantwortete oder eine
alternative dazu wäre auch noch dazu
solltest du noch eine flasche von
eingelegten gurken trinken um es nach zu
spülen
ja ich hoffe wir konnten die
weiterhelfen die nächste frage ich uns
anschauen ist wirklich wieder etwas was
vom herzen kommen wo wirklich jemand
seine leidenschaft und seine motivation
etwas im leben zu erreichen mit anderen
leuten teilen will und sich dahingehend
informieren will wo er das ganze
erlernen kann der unterricht wo kann man
den nrw depp unterricht nehmen wäre
bereit fünf kilometer von bochum aus zu
fahren aber bitte nur professionelle
dabei
ja bitte habe ich dir hoffentlich weiter
geholfen
also die nächste frage das ist wirklich
ganz armes deutschland mein freund ruft
mich mit männernamen ich bin seit drei
monaten mit meinem freund zusammen wenn
wir sex haben denn der mich andauernd
kevin
also wenn die frage ernst gemeint ist
und ich hoffe das ist sie nicht an habt
ihr echt ein problem oder dein freund
sie schreibt ihr dann halt noch weiter
ich weiß nicht warum er das tut und er
sagt dass er ein versehen ist der schwul
und vor allen dingen kann ich schwanger
werden wenn er denkt ich sei ein junger
also der supporter die auch schon
geantwortet ich glaube nicht dass die
frage ernst gemeint ist die nächste
frage hier jetzt wieder so komplett
bescheuert ist es normal wenn ein 14
jähriger junge mit einem holz handy
telefoniert
da dachte ich erst sie meint mit holz
handy einfach irgendein billiges handy
diensten sollen begriff so etwas hast du
denn fürn holz handy wenn das handy
einfach scheiße ist aber sie schreibt
hier vorweg ich rede von meinem ex es
sehr komisch wenn wir reden guckt er die
ganze zeit auf sein handy holz handy und
tut so als ob das tingeln würde wort
wenn es klingelt dann macht er so
geräusche ding ding ding und danach
hallo mama ich komme heute mit meiner ex
nach hause
das stimmt gar nicht und dann wenn er so
sagt er mama ich bin noch in meiner ex
denkt er dass er das einer vor allem ich
bin noch in meiner ex chef vor er ist
ein 14 jähriger junge
in seiner ex geht an sein handy und
sagen da ist aber ich bin doch in meiner
ex was ist los mit manchen menschen
süchtig nach katzen füßen bin ich normal
ich hebe meine katzen oft hoch und
rieche anderen hinterpfoten die haben so
einen typischen katzen fußgeruch und ich
liebe den bin ich verrückte soll ich
mich einweisen lassen
das ist ganz ganz ganz übel die nächste
frage wurde wahrscheinlich von seiner
person wie babys beauty palace oder so
gestellt ich habe einen eiswürfel im
ganzen runtergeschluckt und er ist noch
nicht wieder raus gekommen was soll ich
machen
ja das ist ganz gefährlich ich hatte
letztens einen eiswürfel auch vom teller
liegen und der hotel geklaut
der weg von einem 15 weggenommen und
hatte einfach wasser hin geschüttet
haben wir allerdings nur noch zur
letzten frage meine damen und herren die
ist wieder gar nicht mal so dumm aber
irgendwie auch schon doch ziemlich dumm
wartet der strom hinter der speck diese
ganz im ernst
so was ähnliches habe ich mich wirklich
schon mal gefragt was ich nicht halt
gefragt habe war ganz einfach ob eine
steckdose sag ich mal auch strom
verbraucht wenn ein ladekabel drin
steckt aber nichts am ladekabel hängt
willst du was ich meine
und nein tut sie nicht habe ich dann
erfahren nachdem er hat mich erst mal
ausgedacht hat anders stelle sich das
heutige video ist allerdings abend meine
damen und herren wenn ihr euch meine
reaktion auf einige der dümmsten
gutefrage.net fragen gefallen hat das
gamer einen like das schaffen wir 40.000
likes eine große zahl aber ich glaube
das video war ganz unterhaltsam und wenn
ich das noch mal machen soll dann lasst
den daumen hoch bei diesem video da es
gibt wirklich noch so unfassbar viele
dumme fragen wie auf dieser plattform
hergestellt wurden ich weiß dass einige
andere youtuber hier auch eine serie zu
haben und da irgendwie die dümmsten
gutefrage.net fragen sie sich ausgesucht
haben ich hab das ja selber vor einigen
jahren schon mal gemacht auf meinem
kanal
deswegen dachte ich mache jetzt mal
einen zweiten teil wie gesagt jetzt euch
gefallen hat schreibt mir gern und in
die kommentare lassen leiter und jetzt
kommt das auto
[Musik]